quelques petites secondes maintenant oui
quelques secondes et je peux vous dire
déjà la première question qui va être
posée portera sur la situation en
guadeloupe vous l'avez entendu la cloche
vient de sonner donc je vous laisse avec
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement première question sur la
voie d'eau
a reçu d'observation y'en a t'il en
séance
cédant à pois il est donc adoptée sous
les réserves visage
madame la ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues je
souhaite d'abord présenté au nom du cdh
à des voeux de prompt rétablissement
premier ministre tué adressé un message
d'ailleurs ce matin même
notre ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
je vous rappelle que la science est
retransmise en direct sur public sénat
et sur notre site internet saka sera
attentif au respect les uns et les
autres bien celui du temps de parole
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue victorin lurel
pour le groupe socialiste
et écologiste
la parole le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre et
outre mer j'y associe mes collègues
victoire jasmin catherine conconne
aimerais santis depuis plusieurs jours
la guadeloupe est littéralement sous des
feux
un seul ministre une autre menace plane
celle de la contagion et de l'extension
du domaine de la lutte des luttes
sanitaire au combat idéologique et
politique plus globaux la martinique et
la guyane son assise au bord d'un volcan
la polynésie a lancé son premier préavis
de grève générale et il suffit d'une
étincelle vous déclenchez un brasier en
nouvelle calédonie à quelques jours du
référendum
2009 est toujours là pour nous instruire
et pourtant j'estime que vous auriez pu
protéger pointe à pitre livrée à elle
même un autre demande le premier
ministre nous a longuement reçu au delà
du nécessaire journée sécuritaire
pourriez vous informer la représentation
nationale les suites concrètes du plan
d'action global systémiques et
structurels
annocé et son calendrier à court et à
moyen terme face aux résistances comment
prévenir une cinquième vague et sauver
des vies nos collègues juillet karoutchi
et arnaud vous ont ici fait des
propositions qui pourrait vous inspirer
pour vous répondre la parole autorise
des outre-mer
monsieur sébastien les corps nus vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président du sénat mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs et sénatrices monsieur le
ministre lurel j'aimerais déjà rendre
hommage à votre courage dans les prises
de position que vous avez eue sur la
vaccination en guadeloupe car tout le
monde ne l'a pas fait et vous l'avez
fait avec un sens de l'état et un sens
de la république qui convient le
semble-t-il d'être souligné ici dans cet
hémicycle des réponses simples mais
clair le première bien évidemment c'est
le retour à l'ordre public le ministre
de l'intérieur a annoncé il ya
maintenant quelques jours des renforts
importants du raid et du gign parce
qu'il faut le dire celles et ceux qui
cassent et qui s'en prennent aux forces
de l'ordre la nuit en tirant à balles
réelles sur eux n'ont rien à voir avec
des manifestants nous avec des personnes
formant des revendications sanitaires la
réponse pénale est en cours pratiquement
une centaine d'interpellations dont je
vous parle la deuxième des choses bien
sûr c'est de poursuivre le dialogue
monsieur le ministre la loi de la
république votée par l'assemblée
nationale le sénat et validés par le
conseil constitutionnel doit s'appliquer
sur l'obligation vaccinale des soignants
sur l'hexagone mais aussi dans les
territoires d'outre-mer néanmoins cette
autorité de la loi ne serait écrasé un
dialogue social entre un employeur et
ses employés donc olivier ferrand a
décidé de mettre en place une structure
qui va permettre de trouver une solution
à chacune des 1400 personnes suspendues
au moment où nous parlons parce que
n'est pas en conformité avec cette
obligation vaccinale un chiffre
peut-être il y avait il ya quelques
jours trois cent cinquante cinq médecins
de ville libéraux qui n'était suspendu
parce que non vaccinés 150 personnes
viennent désormais de se mettre en
situation de conformité en se vaccinant
on sera amené à vous rendre compte
évidemment très prochainement de l'avant
c'est pareil au sein du sdiss ou une
mission est là pour aider le dialogue
social entre les élus du département et
les syndicats de sapeurs pompiers demain
après midi monsieur le ministre on nous
réunirons l'ensemble dès élus de la
guadeloupe il s'agira non seulement de
parler des mesures sanitaires mais aussi
de la jeunesse parce que c'est elle qui
se retrouve sur les barrages deux ans de
vie de son passé par là avec une
jeunesse d eux vous l'avez de votre
question vous en remercie la question de
l'arrivée la cinquième vague aussi dans
les territoires d'outre-mer de nous
préoccuper et je vous annonce donc
monsieur le ministre que nous allons
sans tarder rétablir les tests avant
embarquement pour les personnes
vaccinées comme non vaccinés qui se
rendent l'hexagone vers les territoires
d'outre-mer à votre disposition d'aucun
monsieur ministre
merci je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre votre réponse mais j'ose vous
dire que quelle que soit la qualité des
réponses elles ne seront jamais
suffisant pour certains qui travaille
déjà sur d'autres registres on ne répond
pas à une crise anthropologique et j'ose
dire ontologique psychologique et
existentielle par des réponses unique
prof matérielles et financières
il faut une réponse politique sans
sombrer dans le lard d'âge car si rist
la question de confiance devra être tôt
ou tard posées aux élites et au peuple
guadeloupéen celle du vouloir vivre
ensemble
voulez vous oui ou non rester dans
l'ensemble français il faudra bien faire
tomber les masques
[Applaudissements]
la parole est un autre collègue henri
cabanel pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen la
parole mon cher collègue merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture
quand ça ne va pas nous le disons mais
quand ça va il faut le dire aussi hier
avec vos collègues le ministre de la
santé le secrétaire d'état chargé des
retraites et de la santé au travail vous
avez présenté votre feuille de route
dédiée à la prévention du mal être et
l'accompagnement des agriculteurs en
difficulté avec un budget en hausse de
12 millions d'euros je salue la méthode
collaborative ou que vous avez choisi
vous êtes largement inspiré du travail
du parlement en puisant des mesures dans
le rapport de notre collègue olivier da
maison et dans celui que j'ai corrigé à
et ma collègue le français serra vous
avez bien compris la nécessité de mettre
l'humain dans les relations entre les
agriculteurs les administrations et les
autres partenaires vous avez changé de
paradigme pour aller vers elle laissa le
soin aux comités départementaux de
choisir leur sentinelle qui seront
formés pour détecter vous avez apporté
des budgets supplémentaires allaient de
répit à l'aide à la relance de
l'exploitation agricole avait quelques
mesures déjà votées dans le plfss comme
le capital décès pour les exploitants
agricoles monsieur le ministre vous
n'avez pas répondu à notre demande
d'étude sur le nombre réel de suicides
chaque année c'est essentiel pour
comprendre la typologie du mal être se
plaint va-t-il progresser ou d'autres
mesures de notre rapport s est ce qu'une
évaluation des résultats est prévue dans
le temps
on vous répond la parole et ministre de
l'agriculture d'alimentation monsieur de
normandie vous avez la parole merci
beaucoup monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les les sénateurs monsieur
le sénateur cabanel oui à l'évidence les
mesures que nous avons
annoncé hier pour lutter contre les
situations de détresse agricole vont
continuer à évoluer dans le temps et je
crois que c'est bien normal et c'est ce
dont nous sommes convenus hier permettez
moi tout d'abord de vous remercier à mon
tour de vous remercier vous même
monsieur le sénateur mais également
madame la sénatrice ferrat pour la
qualité des travaux que vous avez mené
pendant presque un an travaux sur
lesquels nous nous sommes appuyés avec
se fait par vos collègues de l'assemblée
nationale notamment le député d'annezin
le constat il est absolument tragique le
constat c'est que oui il ya une sur
mortalité par suicide dans le domaine
agricole et que ce constat tragique ces
drames familiaux ces drames territoriaux
il nous oblige nous tous collectivement
à agir avec beaucoup plus de force pour
lutter contre ces détresses agricole
c'est tout le sens des mesures
ambitieuses que nous avons annoncé hier
ambitieux sur le fond ambitieuse aussi
sur les moyens puisque les budgets sont
en augmentation de plus de 40% avec
différents dispositifs que vous avez
évoquées dans votre question ambitieux
sur la forme je le disais parce que ces
mesures elle vit elle vise trois axes
d'abord le aller vers toutes politiques
sociales telles que celles menées avec
mes collègues olivier ferrand et laurent
pietra chef qui doivent reposer sur le
aller vers ensuite remettre de
l'humanisation dans toutes les
procédures aujourd'hui il n'est plus
possible d'envoyer des agriculteurs qui
sont en difficulté des lettres de
recouvrement pour quelques euros ce
n'est pas normal c'est envoyer
machinalement de manière automatique il
nous faut remettre de l'humain là dessus
et je salue les engagements pris par
exemple par la msa sur ce sujet et enfin
un accompagnement un accompagnement
économique financier administratif
médico social qui est absolument
important mais n'oublions pas mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs qu'il faut
surtout traiter le sujet à la racine
redonner rémunération et considération
au monde agricole rémunération et
considérations re donnons de la valeur à
notre alimentation
merci monsieur le ministre je vais en
profiter pour remercier la commission
des affaires économiques et sa
présidente sophie primas qui nous a
permis de réaliser ce travail
je voudrais aussi remercier
edouard baer jaune qui par rapport à son
film au nom de la terre nous a donné ce
déclic qui nous a permis ce travail est
qui et qui a surtout permis de ne pas
faire de ce sujet un sujet tabou et de
nous permettre donc de travailler
effectivement d'avoir des mesures
adéquates je voudrais aussi remercier
mon groupe le rdse qui m'a permis aussi
de déposer cette ppl mais vous avez
raison monsieur le ministre si nous
avons tourné la page de la prévention il
faut continuer le chapitre sur la
rénumération de nos agriculteurs parce
qu'il n'y a que comme ça qu'on arrivera
à baisser le nombre de suicides dans ce
pays
merci
la parole et un autre collègue mélanie
vogel pour le groupe écologie solidarité
et territoires
merci merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre demain nous sommes le 25
novembre journée internationale pour
l'élimination des violences faites à
l'égard des femmes lundi dernier nous
avons été près de 300 femmes actives en
politique certaines sont assis ici dans
l'hémicycle a signé un texte pour
demander au monde politique de tirer les
leçons du mouvement me to avec des
demandes très clair ne pas parrainer
pour les présidentielles des agresseurs
ne pas investir des agresseurs aux
législatives et ne pas embaucher des
agresseurs pourquoi pourquoi demandé
d'écarter les agresseurs du monde
politique parce que les verts parce que
les violences sexistes et sexuelles sont
un système
au delà des souffrances des traumas des
cauchemars des nausées des insomnies les
violences sexistes et sexuelles
poursuivre un but politique précis
ramener les femmes un statut d'objet
nier leur capacité à occuper leur place
dans la société et progressivement en
faisant de leur vie professionnelle et
politique un enfer
les détourner des sphères de pouvoir
la clé de voûte de ce système madame la
ministre celle qui pourrait notre
société qui l'empêchent d'avancer c'est
l'impunité
l'impunité envoie aux agresseurs un
message très clair il ne se passera rien
continuer et aux missions et aux
victimes un message tout aussi claire on
ne vous croit pas ou si on vous croit on
s'en fout aucune ministre n'a signé la
tribune aucune parlementaires de la
majorité présidentielle le gouvernement
n'a pas réagi bien sûr tout le monde
comprend ici que vous soyez gênée pour
ma part et je vais très clair je ne
jetterai lapierre a aucune femme qui n'a
ni les moyens ni le courage de signer un
texte pareil mais le silence
gouvernemental blesse alors j'ai une
question très simple et que l'on soit
clair je ne vous demande pas de me
parler des années qui viennent de
s'écouler et de votre bilan je vous
demande de me parler de l'avenir est ce
que vous vous engagez oui ou non aux
demandes de la tribune et si oui comment
pour vous répondre la parole et à la
milice de l'idiot en charge de l'égalité
a pris femme faisait désordre de la
diversité d'égalité des chances de la
mort et d'autres vous avez la parole de
la ministre je vous remercie monsieur le
président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices madame la sénatrice au gel
j'ai vu cette tribune évidemment comme
je suis toutes les actions qui se tourne
autour de la libération de la parole des
femmes dans notre pays que ce soit dans
la sphère publique ou dans la sphère
privée j'ai vu vos doléances dans cette
tribune et j'ai surtout vu votre
négation de toutes les actions que ce
gouvernement a mis en place pour lutter
contre les violences faites aux femmes
depuis 2010 est on peut nous reprocher
beaucoup de choses mais il ya une chose
qui est certaine et je le dis de manière
factuelle et concrète c'est qu'aucun
gouvernement avant celui ci n'a autant
lutter contre les violences et toutes
les formes de violences faites aux
femmes
alors ça peut être désagréable à
entendre mais encore une fois c'est ce
gouvernement qui a fait le grenelle des
violences conjugales c'est ce
gouvernement qui a augmenté de 60 % le
nombre de places d'hébergement pour
accueillir les victimes c'est encore ce
gouvernement qui a formé plus de 90
mille policiers et gendarmes pour
accueillir la parole des victimes
c'est encore ce gouvernement qui s'est
occupée des enfants qui s'est occupée
des auteurs alors je veux bien qu'on
nous reproche beaucoup de choses mais
pas le fait de ne pas agir et sauf
erreur de ma part dans cette tribune il
était dit que cette grande cause du
quinquennat n'existait pas alors je peux
vous dire les yeux dans les yeux que je
soutiens évidemment cette demande que
vous formulez mais je ne soutiens
absolument pas le constat du bilan que
vous faites de la grande cause du
quinquennat
la parole est à notre collègue dany
wattebled pour le groupe les
indépendants
la parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre collègues
les britanniques voulaient faire le bris
site ils l'ont imposé nous l'avons
négocier et l'ont accepté ils veulent
maintenant le renégocier le prix si tu
ne veux pas éternel et les européens ne
veut pas le subir indéfiniment
après avoir tourné le dos à l'europe il
est temps que les britanniques assument
leur choix
qu'ils assument que les trois quarts de
leur exposition de pêche dépend du
marché européen qu'ils assument de
mettre en péril une relation d'amitié
politique économique pour 0,1 pour cent
de leur produit intérieur brut la taxe
ailleurs brut pardon monsieur le
ministre il nous faut donc clore ce bras
de fer en faisant respecter l'accord
post briques 6 sur la pêche afin que nos
pêcheurs ne soit pas sacrifiée sur
l'autel du bric site
nous demandons un engagement fort de la
part de la commission européenne
les britanniques jouent avec mauvaise
foi soit le justificatif prévu par
l'accord de retrait dans mon territoire
du nord c'est une angoisse permanente
nos pêcheurs souffre il manquerait
encore ce jour environ 150 licence
après avoir annoncé fin octobre des
sanctions qui doivent prendre effet
début novembre le président macron a
décidé de les suspendre dans le sud 2-2
escalade pour laisser à valider les eaux
britanniques mais le premier ministre
brian stone l'a pas saisie le
gouvernement a promis une décision avant
noël mais le temps presse
'l'annonce d'un plan de sortie de flotte
sonne comme un renoncement aux oreilles
des pêcheurs qu'en est il de l'état
d'avancement des négociations pour la
délivrance des sens de pêche manquantes
concrètement quelle sauce on quelle
sanction dite croisés en visio ou de
prendre en cas de non réponse près de
deux cent douze bateaux dépend de
l'accès aux eaux britanniques dans les
eaux france et taxer encore plus
important puisque 60 % des captures de
pêche proviennent de ces eaux il
convient donc de s'assurer que les
britanniques respecte l'accord qu'ils
ont signé en l'appliquant entièrement
merci monsieur le ministre de nous dire
où nous en sommes
[Applaudissements]
en charge des affaires européennes
monsieur clément beau monsieur le
ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur va tablette vous avez raison de
revenir sur ce qu'est le break site
c'est un choix souverain et britannique
que nous regrettons mais que nous
respectons qui nous a déjà beaucoup
occupé au niveau européen ça au trot et
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas en subir
les conséquences un accord a été trouvé
ce que nous demandons je le rappelle
c'est son plein et simple respect et
nous avons besoin vous l'avez rappelé
vous avez raison de maintenir une
relation qui par l'histoire la
géographie entre la france et le royaume
uni entre l'union européenne et le
royaume uni est essentiel sur les plans
stratégique géo politique culturelle
économique humain etc mais pour
construire une relation forte ce même
après le break site nous avons besoin de
confiance nous avons besoin de lever
tout malentendu nous avons besoin de
respecter les accords signés et les
paroles donnez nous le faisons nous
attendons du royaume uni que ce soit
fait également et pour construire cette
relation de confiance je le dis
simplement une faute aussi être deux
nous sommes prêts à le faire mais nous
n'avons pas ces signaux de confiance et
de respect de la part du royaume uni
suffisamment clair aujourd'hui la
question de la pêche s'inscrit dans ce
contexte avec annick girardin nous y
travaillons fortement son autorité dû
prendre la république et du premier
ministre parce que nous ne pouvons pas
faire subir ces difficultés à nos
pêcheurs ça fait onze mois qu'on négocie
nous avons obtenu heureusement un nombre
important de licences mais il en reste
un nombre trop important qui ne sont pas
aujourd'hui principalement dans les îles
anglo normandes dans les eaux des îles
anglo normandes et autour des hauts de
france disponible et donner à nos
pêcheurs alors nous avons haussé le ton
il ya quelques semaines cela a permis de
reprendre un dialogue pour l'obtention
de ces distances nous sommes à cette
phase de discussion qui est parfois
difficile
reconnaissons le est le prendre la
république a été extrêmement clairs nous
l'avons été la semaine dernière
continuons encore quelques jours ce
dialogue en lui donnant sa chance car ce
serait une meilleure solution pour tout
le monde y compris pour les britanniques
je le redis d'avoir une solution apaisée
et concertée si ce n'était pas le cas
nous défendrons nos intérêts nous
n'avons jamais hésité à le faire à le
dire et nous mettrons en application ses
dialogues ne porte pas ses fruits notre
objectif reste le même défend les
intérêts de nos pêcheurs faire appliquer
strictement les accords signés nous les
accompagnons toujours
la parole est un autre collègue philippe
dominati pour le groupe les résultats
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président d'abord mes collègues m'ont
demandé de s'associer voeux de
rétablissement du premier ministre comme
vous l'avez fait en début de séance
monsieur le ministre la semaine dernière
la cour des comptes a publié un rapport
de 22 pages qui souligne que les
difficultés de notre police nationale
proviennent essentiellement ou en tout
cas pour l'essentiel de la mauvaise
gestion des ressources humaines du
ministère
la cour constate que en dix ans une
augmentation de 21 % de la masse
salariale s'est traduite malheureusement
par une absence sur le terrain des
policiers de l'ordre de 37 % la cour
constate également que les budgets de
fonctionnement et d'investissement ont
été fortement impactés
à cause de cette forte augmentation de
la masse salariale la cour juge
inadaptée les systèmes de formation
aussi bien des gardiens de la paix que
des officiers de police et surtout
condamne les expérimentations depuis
huit ans des cycles horaires qui ont
conduit à l'explosion des heures
supplémentaires mais surtout la cour
rappelle qu'en 1970 en
2017 déjà elle avait souligné que
l'abondance de biens et de moyens et
matériels ne suffirait pas s'il n'y
avait pas de réforme de structure alors
ma question est simple de quels moyens
ou de quelle de latitude vous disposez
dans le - qui reste dans ce quinquennat
pour un tas mais enfin les réformes de
structure que notre police nationale
attend depuis longtemps
on connaît l'état
gérald darmanin ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur cet
ordinateur vous avez raison et le
rapport de la cour des comptes sonne
juste et sonne juste puisque le rapport
et les magistrats le dixième depuis
grosso modo 2000 2010 2011
l'augmentation très forte de la masse
salariale s'est traduit évidemment par
une pesanteur beaucoup trop forte par
rapport à l'investissement notamment
matériels de nos forces de police mais
également avec des diminutions
d'effectifs puisqu'on a compensé les
diminutions d'effectifs par des cycles
horaire qui étaient soit avantageux ou
des heures supplémentaires extrêmement
nombreuses
dans son gouvernement si chacun se
rappelle de ce qu'a fait mon
prédécesseur a en partie payé ses heures
supplémentaires ou des départs en
retraite plus tôt que ce qui était prévu
de fait de ses heures supplémentaires et
nous avons changé à sa semble de choses
et le présent dans la pluie qui l'a
annoncé lors de la conclusion du bureau
de la sécurité à roubaix d'où la loi de
programmation qui m'a demandé de
conduire être présenter très
prochainement au premier ministre et au
président de la république pour le
conseil des ministres avant cela nous
avons déjà pris deux grandes discussions
salariales qui nous permettra pour le
mois de janvier donc faut grosso modo le
1er janvier monsieur le sénateur d'abord
le rétrécissement du nombre de cycles
horaires possibles pour les policiers
avec l'abandon des cycles horaires trop
consommateur si j'ose dire de force
notamment la vacation forte et nous
serons le premier gouvernement à mettre
fin à ce système de vacation forte je
crois que c'est à la fois attendu et ce
sera nécessaire et conforme à ce qu'on
voudrait la cour des comptes et les
parlementaires mais également le système
qui permet de mettre les policiers là où
on en a besoin et non pas avoir à me
that her qui ne peut affecter des
policiers que à la sortie d'école et pas
pendant les trente ans de vie ensuite
des fonctionnaires vous l'avez je crois
souligné monsieur sénateurs parce que
malgré le rejet du budget présenté par
le gouvernement vous avez accepté dans
votre commission des lois jean mercier
des commissaires les crédits du
ministère de l'intérieur sans doute est
il pas si mauvais que cela
dominés
chez lui malheureusement vous n'avez pas
répondu à ma question qui étaient les
réformes structurelles la vacation forte
elle a été établi par un gouvernement
dans lequel le ministre de l'économie
des finances appelé emmanuel macron donc
ce n'est pas nous qui lavons et les
fallu six ans pour corriger cette erreur
est les consommatrices de crédit et
moyennant quoi il y avait plus de moyens
de fonctionnement les réformes de
structure on les attend et vous répondez
comme malheureusement vos prédécesseurs
parce que sans doute le président la
république ne s'intéresse qu'à la fin du
quinquennat world des réformes de
structure qu'il aurait dû entamer au
début une loi de programmation ne se
fait pas entre deux quinquennats
c'est tout à fait anormal il aurait
fallu dès le début du quinquennat entamé
des structures des réformes de structure
sur la police sur le renseignement
intérieur enfin tout ce qu'on attendait
à la fin du quinquennat précédent
la parole est à madame la présidente
valérie létard pour le groupe de l'union
centriste vous avez la parole madame la
présidente
merci
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
jeudi soir dernier votre ministère
monsieur ministre s'est félicité d'être
parvenu à un accord avec l'ars talent le
propriétaire allemand de la syrie à
scovell de saint saulve lequel a renoncé
à la délocalisation de près de 40% de
l'activité du site français en allemagne
c'est un soulagement pour les 300
employés du site mais ne nous leurrons
pas les raisons qui ont amené le groupe
allemand envisage et la délocalisation
n'ont pour autant pas disparu en effet
le site valenciennois d'ascq ovale et
comme tant d'autres étranglé par la
hausse brutale des prix de l'électricité
multiplié par trois depuis le début de
l'année ayant choisi l'électrification
plutôt que les hauts fourneaux ayant
fait l'effort d'investir dans
l'industrie verte ils en paient le prix
monsieur le ministre comment expliquer à
nos industriels qui jouent le jeu et
s'engageant la décarbonation que cela se
fait au détriment de leur compétitivité
comment justifier une telle
schizophrénie de la réglementation
européenne alors même que le mix
énergétique nationale est parmi les plus
décarbonés d'europe nous n'en récolte
pas les fruits au contraire nos
entreprises en sont punis votre réponse
exclusivement budgétaire me semble
timide ponctuelles et sans stratégie de
long terme à ce que veulent comme bien
d'autres entreprises attendent plus
permettez moi monsieur le ministre de
vous interroger à l'aune de lattre la
très prochaine présidence française de
l'union européenne quels sont les
convictions vous comptez défendre pour
protéger notre souveraineté industrielle
enfin quel est votre plan pour inscrire
ce sujet à l'agenda et faire bouger
concrètement et rapidement les choses à
défaut combien de délocalisation
énergétique d'ici 2025 devrons nous
supporter
[Applaudissements]
la parole est aux milices de l'économie
des finances et de la relance monsieur
bruno le maire en jamais la parole
monsieur venir
[Applaudissements]
un seul être vous manque et tout est
dépeuplé
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
suis heureux de vous retrouver sur le
président également
madame la présidente létard je veux
qu'il y ait aucune ambiguïté nous sommes
battus ensemble avec les salariés avec
les syndicats avaient kg locaux avec
vous personnellement madame la
présidente je vous remercie de votre
engagement pour chauffer à ce qu'au val
il a quatre ans pour leur offrir des
perspectives de développement économique
pour avoir une grande aciérie décarbonée
nous continuerons à nous battre nous
avons empêché la délocalisation d'ascq
ovale il n'y aura pas de délocalisation
d'ascq ovale ni maintenant ni plus tard
en revanche
je veux vous rassurer aussi sur la
stratégie que nous avons nous voulons
aller vers une économie décarbonée et
vous avez raison ça un coup
produire une tonne d'acier avec un fouet
électrique dans une aciérie décarbonés
ses 150 euros de plus la tonne
actuellement au regard des prix de
l'électricité je rappelle que de l'autre
côté c'est ce qu'on oublie trop souvent
une tonne d'acier produites chez archi
talent produite avec un haut fourneau
classique c'est deux tonnes de co2 qui
sont tennis alors il faut choisir ainsi
véritablement nous voulons aller vers
une économie décarbonée verde à cirer
des carbonnais qui émettent peu de co2
c'est notre choix c'est notre choix et
barbara pompili si notre choix avec
l'ensemble dû gouvernement et nous
tiendrons ce choix stratégique pour
l'économie française mais sa demande
effectivement de prendre si des
décisions de long terme pour anticiper
cette augmentation des coûts la première
décision la première bataille que nous
avons commencé à livrer et que je livre
personnellement au conseil des ministres
de l'économie c'est de découpler le prix
d'électricité du prix du gaz
la france n'a pas à payer l'augmentation
des prix du gaz par une augmentation de
ses prix d'électricité alors qu'elle
avait centrales nucléaires qui lui
permettent d'avoir des coûts faibles le
production électrique et je me battrai
pour ce découplage parce qu'il est
indispensable pour l'économie est
indispensable pour l'environnement le
deuxième point c'est de faire payer le
co2 c'est le projet fit for fit five que
nous coûte pour lequel nous nous battons
avec un présent la république et la
troisième condition stratégique c'est de
mettre en place une taxe carbone aux
frontières
car nous voulons faire payer l'acier
carbonées à tous ceux qui veulent faire
rentrer de l'acier sur les territoires
européens
le président
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre nous partageons cela la
compétition économique d'aujourd'hui ne
joue qu'avec la chaîne yoopa qu'avec la
chine et le brésil au sein même de
l'union nous devons défendre notre
compétitivité vous venez de le rappeler
une urgence changer le mode de
tarification notre énergie reconnaître
le nucléaire comme énergie décarbonée ne
plus être uniquement dans une approche
curative mais dans l'anticipation c'est
la clé de notre souveraineté
industrielle est à l'image des sujets
vallourec saint saulve ou bente l'air
dans l'yonne cher dominique vais rien
qui sont devant nous il nous faut
reprendre la main et ne plus subir c'est
ce qu'on attend d'autre part monsieur le
ministre nous défendre auprès de
l'europe la présidence française de
l'union européenne doit être un
accélérateur de ces changements
merci
la parole est à notre collègue jeremy
baky pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologique avec la
parole monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues en
préambule je souhaiterais exprimer toute
la solidarité de l'ensemble des membres
du groupe crc eu envers les populations
d'outre-mer en lutte actuellement contre
la vie chère et contre fracturé public n
dont ils et elles sont victimes depuis
trop longtemps maintenant madame la
ministre une date symbolique celle du 25
novembre est en approche journée
internationale pour l'élimination des
violences à l'égard des femmes ces
violences aggravées par la précarité
précarité allant même parfois jusqu'à la
marchandisation des corps existe partout
au sein du domicile familial sur les
lieux de travail dans la rue ou encore
sur internet le 20 novembre dernier
c'est ce qu'a dénoncé la foule immense
qui a défilé à paris autant de personnes
sont encore attendus ce week-end samedi
à marseille alors je sais vous l'avez
expliqué précédent on vous avait tout
bien fait mais voilà les chiffres sont
là ils ne sont malheureusement pas bon
et votre auto satisfaction n'en est que
plus indécente durant le confinement les
appels pour violences conjugales ont
triplé et les chiffres continuent
progresser le 18 novembre 2000 21 101
féminicide été dénombrées soit déjà 11
de plus qu'en 2020 au total ce sont cinq
cent quarante trois femmes qui ont perdu
la vie depuis 2010 est aussi je vous le
demande quand allez vous enfin prendre
la mesure de la gravité de la situation
et mettre en place un véritable plan
ambitieux de lutte contre ces violences
insupportables
pour vous répondre la parole est
monsieur le garde des sceaux ministre de
la justice monsieur eric dupond moretti
vous avez la parole
je pensais au fond monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs qu'il
suffisait de partir et de revenir pour
entendre la ola mais
ce n'est pas tout à fait exact monsieur
monsieur le monsieur le sénateur baki
d'abord je voudrais vous dire que
puisque vous avez d'emblée évoqué la
situation en guadeloupe je n'ai pas ce
sentiment quant à moi qu'il puisse
s'agir d'une fracture républicaine ça je
tiens à vous le dire pour le reste nous
avons pris je crois la mesure de ce que
sont les violences faites aux femmes et
l'impérieuse nécessité de lutter contre
ces violences et je vais vous rappeler
un certain nombre de choses ne vous en
déplaise d'abord nous avons déployés
dans toutes les juridictions de ce pays
des bracelets anti-rapprochement et dès
qu'un bracelet anti rapprochement est
utilisé il est immédiatement remplacé
par la chancellerie nous avons déployé
3036 prime téléphone grave danger ce qui
évite au quotidien des infractions des
plus légères aux plus graves nous avons
accéléré la procédure d'ordonnancé de
protection elles seront aujourd'hui en
six jours et c'est une augmentation de
140% monsieur le sénateur de ces
ordonnances nous avons augmenté en
matière de médecine légale le budget de
30 % 30 % dédié naturellement victime
les dépôts de plainte à l'hôpital 80
conventions ont été signées entre les
parquets et les hôpitaux nous avons en
matière d' aide aux victimes augmenté de
25% notre budget nous avons mis en place
la réalité virtuelle pour le suivi des
auteurs nous avons ouvert 27 centres de
prise en charge des auteurs et trois
sont en cours d'ouverture et nous avons
considérablement augmenté l'hébergement
des victimes et l'hébergement des
auteurs voilà monsieur le sénateur ce
qui me paraît de nature à vous dire très
clairement que nous avons pris la mesure
du problème et bien sûr notre travail
n'est pas terminé
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre d'abord je vous
réponds rapidement sur la guadeloupe
puisque vous l'avez fait d'une phrase
lorsque l'égalité républicaine est pas
accordée sur l'ensemble du territoire y
compris sur les autos mère je considère
qu'il y a une fracture républicaine ce
que nous demandons monsieur le ministre
c'est d'opérer un véritable de police un
véritable virage politique globale en la
matière en allouant un budget ambitieux
qui manque aujourd'hui cruellement pas
moins de 1 milliard d'euros d'autres
pays européens l'ont fait comme
l'espagne par exemple un tel budget
permettrait l'adoption et l'application
d'une loi cadre que nous soutenons
depuis des années d'une unité de police
spécialisée et surtout former un réel
accompagnement des victimes le
renforcement de la prévention et la
prise en charge des auteurs de telles
violences dès le plus jeune âge la
france doit être au rendez vous sans
quoi nous considérerions que dans ce
pays la condition de millions de femmes
vous malheureusement bien moins que
milliards d'euros
le collègue l'a déjà vu pour le groupe
du rassemblement des démocrates pour va
ici c'est indépendant la parole monsieur
le président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame bourguignon
ministre délégué des solidarités et de
la santé et tout d'abord tout d'abord
j'adresse au nom de mon groupe tous mes
voeux de rétablissement au premier
ministre ainsi que sa fille l'épidémie
n'est pas terminée la cinquième vague
est là et les mesures drastiques déjà
prises chesnot ses voisins européens où
la campagne vaccinale n'a pas été aussi
étendue qu'en france le démontre je veux
exprimer ensuite au nom du groupe r des
pays notre sphère ses fiertés à la suite
de l'accord signé avant-hier entre le
gouvernement et plusieurs syndicats
concernant la revalorisation salariale
des sages femmes hospitalières
elles sont près de 24 mille à exercer
leur métier sur nos territoires avec
dévouement et passion
cela faisait plusieurs années qu'elle
attendait cela est désormais actée et
cela fait suite à une autre annonce les
revalorisations salariales accordées
lors du ségur étendue aux vingt mille
salariés des établissements pour
personnes handicapées financé par les
départements ce lundi un collectif
composé d'employeurs les deux syndicats
du secteur social et médico social
auquel se sont passés aussi et leurs
familles s'est mobilisée pour alerter
l'ensemble des parlementaires
finistériens de tous bords sur la crise
que rencontre ce secteur d'activité ils
étaient ainsi une centaine réunis devant
ma permanence à lannilis je tiens ici à
souligner la qualité des échanges qui se
sont déroulés dans un climat de respect
et d'écouté mutuelle madame la ministre
avec mes deux collègues une
parlementaire nous souhaitons que leur
mission si précieuse qu'elle aide à
l'autonomie soit mieux reconnue comment
peut-on les accompagner parmi les
demandes formulées une revalorisation la
mise en oeuvre d'une convention
collective qu'ils attendent depuis plus
de 40 ans et plus généralement un
soutien à l'attractivité de leurs
métiers qui sont des emplois locaux non
délocalisables dans des zones rurales
ces cinquante mille professionnels qui
sont concernés en bretagne je vous
remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est qu'a
commise délégué en charge de colomiers
manager merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice n'a déjà vers la
crise a noté sanitaire a montré
l'importance du système sanitaire fort
mais aussi la prise en charge sociale et
médico sociale solide nous y répondons
en renforçant l'attractivité en
investissant massivement dans les
établissements et dans les équipements
s'agissant des sages femmes je me
félicite de la signature lundi d'un
protocole d'accord avec la majorité des
organisations syndicales comme vous
venez de le soulever de la fonction
publique hospitalière de la fhf fruit
d'un long travail de concertation et de
la avec le ministère là les syndicats
les organisations des sages femmes nous
venons de reconnaître l'engagement de
ces professionnels à travers cet accord
en dessous en consacrant des avancées
importantes la revalorisation net de 500
euros par mois par sages femmes
hospitalières la création d'une sixième
année de formation en maïeutique la
réaffirmation dans leurs rôles
spécifiques au sein des établissements
de santé gouvernement s'est engagé à ce
que ce protocole appliqué à la fonction
publique soit aussi transposé au secteur
privé les sages-femmes territoriales
bénéficieront donc des mesures de
revalorisation de grille indiciaire
quant aux revalorisations dans le
secteur du social du médico social
c'est plus de 10 milliards d'euros qui
ont été décidées dans le cadre du ségur
puis dans le cadre de ces extensions
vous l'avez rappelé une extension en
faveur de vingt mille professionnels du
secteur du handicap
financé par les départements a été
récemment décidé et c'est d'ailleurs ici
au sénat qu'elle a été adoptée lors du
plfss 2022 c'était une mesure importante
pour prévenir les risques d'inéquité
entre professionnels exerçant la même
activité
nous poursuivons les échanges avec les
représentants médicaux ceux du médico
social comme vous l'avez rappelé
notamment avec le collectif que vous
évoquez dans votre question c'est
l'esprit qui nous anime depuis le début
vous le savez nous avons déjà consacré
beaucoup aussi sur leur valorisation des
aides à 2 ici de la branche de l'aide à
domicile je les ai rencontrés hier je
peux vous assurer qu'il nous remercie
parce que depuis des années il n'avait
pas été revalorisés il y aura d'autres
secteurs parce que comme vous le savez
il y à un morcellement extraordinaire
dans cette dans ce domaine aussi et donc
nous allons continuer comme nous l'avons
fait que le ségur et vous le voyez les
extensions sont toujours là
quelques secondes madame un nom
la parole qu'à notre collègue alain
cadec pour le groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président j'ai bien
entendu tout à l'heure clément bonne
cependant ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre de la mer
madame la ministre le 9 janvier 2020
était signé le traité du bric site avec
son follett son volet pêche qui fut
négocié dans les dernières heures pour
éviter le no deal tant redoutée cet
accord stipule que nos pêcheurs peuvent
continuer à pêcher notamment dans les
îles des dents dans les eaux des îles
anglo normandes s'ils répondent un
certain nombre de conditions en
particulier le principe d antériorité
aujourd'hui les britanniques refuse
d'attribuer un grand nombre de licences
vous nous avez affirmé il ya peu à grand
renfort de formules chocs que la france
ne resterait pas les bras croisés face à
cette occase or à l'occasion du g20 de
rome le président de la république a
rappelé à la suite d'une rencontre avec
boris johnson je cite à une désescalade
s'agit-il d'un désaveu
s'agissant des éventuelles mesures de
rétorsion
cerise sur le gâteau madame la ministre
la semaine dernière vous annoncez
brutalement et sans concertation au
monde de la pêche réunis à saint pol de
léon que le règlement de la crise
nécessiterait un plan de sortie de
flotte pour les navires n'ayant pas
obtenu la licence à laquelle ils peuvent
prétendre
madame la ministre nous sommes passés de
nous sommes prêts à leur couper
l'électricité à nous sommes prêts à
détruire le navire pour les satisfaire
quel grand écart
le monde de la pêche est abasourdi
révolte est écoeuré nous sommes ici face
à une reddition sans condition devant
les diktats des britanniques en effet
quelle humiliation pour la france
d'accepter la destruction de nos navires
pour satisfaire les anglais
madame la ministre les pêcheurs ne
réclame pas d'argent mais le droit
d'exercer leur métier
cette décision si elle est confirmée est
inique et démontre une fois de plus
notre faiblesse en europe et votre
incapacité à mobiliser nos partenaires
de l'union
madame la ministre le gouvernement
confirme t-il cette capitulation
où est il prêt à se ressaisir pour
défendre les intérêts de nos pêcheurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ministre de la mer
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
monsieur le sénateur alain cadec on se
connaît depuis très longtemps et penser
que je puisse cas pas de capitaliser a
renoncé ce pardon renoncer je crois que
vous savez très bien quelle sera ma
réponse le combat il est effective
depuis 11 mois et il ne cesse pas et je
suis régulièrement avec les
professionnels sur le terrain et oui
j'ai pu m'expliquer avec eux sur place
aux assises comme d'ailleurs dans les
hauts de france dimanche alors c'est
quoi la vérité des choses la vérité des
choses c'est que depuis onze mois nous
cessant d'augmenter les dossiers
techniques réclamées par le royaume uni
la vérité des choses c'est que nous nous
battons quotidiennement gouvernement
professionnels élus sauf ceux qui en ce
moment en besoin d'être un peu plus
médiatique et quand oublier l'intérêt
général pour obtenir des licences où on
en est où on en est des licences on est
venu aujourd'hui
85% des licences il aurait effectivement
15 alors pour les britanniques c'est un
détail pour moi c'est capital alors je
continue à me battre pour chacun d'entre
eux je me bats pour chacun d'entre eux
comme d'ailleurs ceux des hauts de
france que vous connaissez bien et
notamment l'armement porcher par exemple
prenant effectivement 7 cet exemple est
un armement qui est extrêmement
dynamique qui achète régulièrement des
nouveaux navires qu'est ce que les
britanniques lui répondent ils lui
répondent qu'il a pas l'antériorité nous
répondons nous répondant navire en place
on nous répondait on avait remplacé avec
une proposition qu'a été reprise par la
commission européenne et qui est
d'ailleurs actuellement depuis 13h on
débat entre le commissaire lui le
commissaire européen et le ministre de
la pêche à anglet la négociation elle
continue et nous irons jusqu'au bout
c'est ce que j'ai dit aux pêcheurs ils
sont d'ailleurs si vous regardez la
totalité de leurs déclarations toujours
derrière le gouvernement est toujours
aligné avec le plus grand nombre ils ont
aujourd'hui annoncé effectivement ils le
feront dans les jours qui viennent leur
volonté est aussi de faire entendre leur
voix à travers des manifestations et
c'est normal ça fait des mois qu'on dit
qu'ils ont énormément de patience et qui
ça fait maintenant onze mois qu'ils
attendent des réponses alors qu'on leur
avait dit à moi qu'est ce que le
président de la république a redit il a
laissé l'espace de dialogue l'espace de
dialogue doit avoir une date limite
cette date limite la commission dans la
donnée au royaume uni c'est sans doute
chose faite dans les clous alors
monsieur le sénateur
l'instrumentalisation des réalisations
politiques
elle ne me fera pas dévier et je serai
là pour chaque pêcheur jusqu'au bout y
compris avec tous les outils que cela
nécessitera
la parole est à notre collègue martin
filles pour le veau socialiste
écologiste et républicaine
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues madame la ministre de brest à
dunkerque 150 bateaux français attendent
des autorisations pour poser leurs chine
et dans les eaux britanniques 11 mois
onze mois après l'entrée en vigueur de
l'accord relatif aux praxis face à la
stratégie délibérée du royaume uni de
refuser l'octroi de ces licences
le gouvernement lui navigue à vue il y a
six semaines madame girardin vous aviez
demandé de vous laisser quinze jours
pour préparer des riposte après avoir
menacé de diminuer l'approvisionnement
en énergie outre manche le gouvernement
a rétropédalé un gant de la reprise du
dialogue
jeudi dernier vous avez évoqué lors des
assises de la pêche une indemnisation
pour les bateaux qui resteraient à quai
sous-entendant une capitulation de la
france le président alors noyé le
poisson cette annonce ont répété
l interpréter et la présidence française
de l'union permettrait de faire entendre
la voix des pêcheurs
l'enlisement de la situation ne présage
rien de bon pour cette présidence mais
surtout ils causent un préjudice
économique et social énorme pour une
population fragilisée qui ne peut plus
attendre la patience des hommes de la
mer est à bout et leur colère est
légitime
sans solutions gouvernementales
il passe à l'action avec des mesures de
répression visant les exportations vers
l'angleterre
madame la ministre trouvez vous normal
que ce soit aux pêcheurs de forcer le
respect de l'accord conclu combien de
temps encore vont ils être otage de ce
sabordage et payer le prix d'une crise
qui est en réalité une crise
diplomatique
je veux
[Applaudissements]
pas parler de madame la mise de la merde
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice martin vial alors j'étais chez
vous dimanche dimanche pour débattre
effectivement avec les pêcheurs mais
également avec l'ensemble de la filière
puisqu'elle est pêcheur bien entendu les
marieurs et il était important que nous
puissions échanger tous ensemble nous
étions au cross gris nez et ça m'a
permis effectivement avec eux de bien
pouvoir lister l'ensemble des
problématiques qui existe avec le
royaume uni mais je veux le redire ici
je leur ai rappelé que la priorité du
gouvernement c'est bien de nous battre
pour obtenir l'ensemble des licences et
vous l'avez dit tous il aurait à peu
près enfin un peu plus de 150 nous nous
battons pour chacune d'elles avec des
arguments précis parce qu'à chaque fois
c'est des cas particuliers pourquoi
parce qu'on est dans les zones proches
de la côte en est avec le plus souvent
dépôt des navires de moins de 12 mètres
sauf effectivement pour les navires
remplaçant que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure c'est donc un travail au cas par
cas mais en même temps et je les assume
totalement en même temps c'est quoi mon
travail de ministre c'est quoi
aujourd'hui
gérer ce sujet c'est prévoir l'avenir
prévoir l'avenir et répondre à chacun
des cas qui se présentera demain
première action bien entendu compte
continuer à mener le combat deuxième
action les oc les accompagner avec
toutes les mesures un plan
d'accompagnement ce plan
d'accompagnement il est présenté en
janvier 2020 il est construit avec les
pêcheurs en fin 2000 2020 n'y a rien de
nouveau dans ce que j'ai dit aux assises
sauf une manipulation politique à la
sortie j'ai rappelé j'ai rappelé les
différentes mesures de ce plan j'ai
rappelé les différentes mesures de ce
plan est effectivement et j'ai parlé à
tous ceux qui avaient et qu'ils allaient
connaître les conséquences du bric site
mais j'ai aussi parlé à ce qu'ils
avaient et qui connaissaient les
conséquences de west med c'est à dire ce
qui se passe en méditerranée à ceux qui
aujourd'hui pêche dans le golfe de
gascogne parce que les difficultés des
pêcheurs ne sont pas que lier même si
c'est le gros dossier à la crise du
break site il se relève aussi de la
crise qu vide et donc ce plan
d'accompagnement et bien ce plan
d'accompagnement il doit se mettre en
place dans les joueurs maintenant
conclure
merci la parole et à notre collègue
laurence garnier
pour le gonflage de luca
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à la ministre chargée de
l'égalité
mais j'aurais pu tout aussi bien la
poser au ministre d'éducation et ce qui
est bien avec ce gouvernement c'est que
la réponse aurait certainement été
complètement différente madame la
ministre
vous êtes favorable à l'utilisation du
pronom yale
vous avez déclaré que pour vous ça
n'était pas si choquant
chacun a bien compris que valider
l'usagé prenons l c'est validé
l'écriture inclusive parce qu'il faudra
qu'on nous explique s'il faut dire ya
les bots ou via les belles donc il
faudra écrire les deux mais pour vous ça
n'est pas si choquant
votre position n'effacera pas les
souffrances de certains parcours de vie
en revanche elle va compliquer l'accès à
la lecture pour des personnes en
situation de handicap et pour nos
enfants dont plus de la moitié n'a pas
un niveau correct de lecture à l'entrée
en sixième mais pour vous ça n'est pas
si choquant votre position madame la
ministre relève de l'idéologie et je
vous cite
pour moi une idéologie c'est mettre dans
la tête de quelqu'un une idée qu'il
n'aurait pas eu seul ce sont vos propos
madame la ministre
que fait-on d'autres en défendant la
neutralité sexuelle et le pr niel que
mettre dans la tête de nos jeunes des
idées qu'il n'aurait pas eu seul
en réalité vous aider
vous aider rocchi sme et au lobby
vous segmenter la société à coups de
poing médian alors que votre rôle en
tant que ministre de la république c'est
de défendre ce qui nous rassemble madame
la ministre l'écriture inclusive exclu
exclus et l'écriture inclusive
[Applaudissements]
en charge de l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes
je vous remercie monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices madame la sénatrice garnier
de la même manière que
edouard philippe avait mentionné il y a
quelques années qu'il était contre
l'écriture inclusive je me suis
également exprimé sur ce sujet et j'ai
dit que l'écriture inclusive pouvait
complexifier la compréhension de la
langue française
et qu'il ne fallait pas prendre cette
direction mais que j'étais totalement
favorable à la féminisation des métiers
pour arrêter d'un visibiliser les femmes
que vous soyez ou d'accord ou pas n'y
changera rien je me suis exprimé
je me suis exprimé sur le fait qu'il
n'était pas nécessaire et pour le coup
pardon de vous le dire mais je suis
totalement d'accord avec le ministre
jean michel blanquer pour dire que je
n'étais pas favorable à l'écriture
inclusive point à la ligne et je vous le
redis non je n'ai pas été choqué que le
petit robert fasse son travail et qu'il
met dans un dictionnaire un terme qui
est déjà dans la société
la parole état de progrès guy stephan
demi pour le groupe de l'union centriste
merci monsieur le président
je souhaite tout d'abord oignons du
groupe union centriste
un prompteur tablissements un monsieur
le premier ministre
monsieur ministre incompréhensible
déséquilibre est néfaste
ce sont les mots utilisés par l'ensemble
des acteurs du secteur aérien pour
qualifié l'accord de libre échange signé
le 18 octobre entre l'union européenne
et le qatar
cet accord entré en application sans
même attendre la ratification des 27
états membres prévoit une ouverture du
ciel européen quasiment illimité pour
qatar airways qui pourrait ainsi
desservir n'importe quelle ville sans
aucune restriction de capacité ou de
fréquences de vol certes des droits ont
été octroyés aux transporteurs européens
mais ils sont complètement déséquilibrée
au regard du faible volume que
représente naturellement la desserte de
doha pour le dire autrement l'accord
donne un accès illimité à un marché de
450 millions d'habitants à qatar airways
en contrepartie d'un manche et qatari de
3 millions d'habitants
cerise sur le gâteau l'accord prévoit
également un accès au marché du fret à
sept compagnies moyen-orientales qui
pourra désormais effectuer des vols
cargo directement entre l'union
européenne et des pays tiers ce n'est
pas anodin car comme vous le savez le
fret aérien a doublé depuis le début de
la pandémie passant de 15 à 30% des
recettes des compagnies l'union
européenne espère vous voyez toute la
force du terme utilisé espère obtenir de
qatar airways le respect des règles de
la concurrence du droit social et de la
transparence des côtes pour éviter
notamment un jumping déguisé avec le
versement comme vous le savez des
massives de la part de l'émirat rien
étant juridiquement clair dans cet
accord c'est un nouveau caillou dans la
chaussure du secteur aérien après la
crise sanitaire ayant mis à genoux à la
fois l'industrie et les compagnies there
yens dans un contexte où certains
activistes de l'avion bashing continuent
à ériger les esprits le secteur aérien
n'avait vraiment pas besoin de cette
nouvelle turbulence monsieur le ministre
les professionnels du monde aéronautique
sont très inquiet et vous invite à ne
pas ratifier cet accord un accord
effectivement incompréhensible
déséquilibré est néfaste pour vous
répondre
on charge du commerce extérieur
monsieur france reste la parole merci
beaucoup monsieur le président mesdames
les sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur stéphane demilly
la france a fait partie des pays
européens qui ont contribué à réviser la
politique commerciale européenne pour en
faire une politique moins naïve plus
assertive plus déterminés à protéger les
entreprises et à prendre en compte les
questions de développement durable
pendant les semaines les mois et les
années qui viennent vous allez avoue
nous allons assister à la mise en place
d'instruments beaucoup plus fort pour
protéger nos entreprises de la
concurrence déloyale en ce qui concerne
cet accord signé le 18 octobre 2021
entre l'union européenne et le kata il
s'agit d'un accord global sur les
services de transport aérien pour
moderniser les règles et les normes qui
régissent les vols entre le qatar et
l'union européenne il a été longuement
des négocié entre 2016 et 2019 il
comprend de nombreuses garanties et
notamment a pris en compte les demandes
des parties françaises européennes et
qatarienne il peut comprend notamment
des dispositions en matière de
transparence financière très novatrice
en matière environnementale très
novatrice en matière aussi sociale est
prêt il comprend des clauses qui
permettent de garantir la concurrence
loyale en la matière au delà des clauses
spécifiques nous allons vérifier que cet
engagement que cet accord sera bien
suivie par les différentes parties
prenantes dans la ligne de ce que nous
mettons en place d'une manière générale
en matière de politique commerciale que
nous appelons les forces montrent la
bonne application des accords
commerciaux et nous serons mobilisés
pour faire en sorte que les engagements
pris soient bien tenu et que les
différentes garanties qui sont dans
l'accord soit respecté par les
différentes parties prenantes
la parole est à notre collègue micheline
jacques pour le groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre la situation de la
guadeloupe nous oblige nous réprouvons
avec force toute forme de violence et
affirmant que ce ne sont pas les jeunes
et la jeunesse qui casse mais bien des
délinquants nous exprimons notre
fraternité à la population qui pâtit des
blocages et des violences
cette crise a des racines profondes que
nous devons tous regarder en face
l'obligation vaccinale n'est qu'un
révélateur et le sentiment de
déconsidération partagé dans l'ensemble
des outre mer a été exacerbée par l'a6
centralisation des politiques publiques
ces derniers mois centraliser qu'on
double autre mère car la distance
accentue l'éloignement de la décision
certes les règles sanitaires doivent
être les mêmes sur l'ensemble de la
république
l'instance de dialogue annoncé par le
premier ministre est donc une première
solution de souplesse pour gérer
l'urgence oui monsieur le ministre la
crise et permanente offenser la relation
avec l'état qui se joue et la capacité
des politiques publiques en général à
répondre aux difficultés structurelles
qui se sont empilées 25 points sont des
jeunes au chômage un tiers de la
population sous le seuil de pauvreté
ajoutant la dignité du manque d'eau
potable
la majorité sénatoriale est attentive à
la crise et regarde au delà comme elle
l'a fait en 2009 avec une mission
commune d'information
il faut en sortir par le haut car on ne
développe pas par à coups le sénat a
fait des propositions solides en matière
de différenciation outre-mer pour
favoriser l'efficacité des politiques
publiques et une relation mieux
articuler entre les collectivités et
l'état le gouvernement est il prêt à
s'engager dans la voie d'un nouveau
pacte de confiance avec les autres
maires français
on vous répond de la parole et nous
promet en effet le corps du père si le
président du sénat monsieur les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice votre
question s'inscrit au fond dans la la
réplique du ministre lurel tout à
l'heure et amène au fond à définir les
mots et à la famille de la
différenciation la décentralisation la
déconcentration
il me semble que dans le cadre de la
gestion de la crise sanitaire nous
l'avons fait d'ailleurs le sénat la
halle à évaluer et pour cause en
fonction des saisons du climat la
circulation du virus la situation
n'était pas la même en fonction des
territoires et on le sait en ce moment
même où deux territoires sont encore
sous état d'urgence sanitaire d'autres
ne le sont pas la différenciation elle
ne l'est pas c'est aussi d'ailleurs par
la stratégie de vaccination à mayotte
typiquement on avait démarré la
vaccination sur des publics plus jeunes
et pour cause la démographie de la
pyramide démographique de lille s'y
prêter votre propre territoire la
sénatrice sous les îles du nord sur
lequel vous êtes très engagé nous avait
permis également de faire cette
différenciation ou saint barth par
exemple était le premier territoire sur
lequel nous avions levé les motifs
impérieux parce que la vaccination était
particulièrement importante la question
que vous posez une question
redoutablement importante elle pose la
question du modèle républicain des
territoires d'outre-mer concernés et
quand on parlait tout à l'heure de
rupture
républicaine une loi de la république
qui est là pour protéger nos concitoyens
comment pourrait-elle - s'appliquer dans
un département d'outre-mer et donc la
vraie question derrière qui est posée
c'est la question de l'autonomie quand
certains élus locaux notamment régionaux
en guadeloupe 10 il faut que les
guadeloupéens puissent décider pour la
guadeloupe bah c'est pas le modèle d'un
départements-régions d'outre-mer si on
est républicain en tout cas républicain
on les met dans la conception ce qui est
un département dans la république ça
porte un autre nom ce sont les
collectivités d'autonomie par exemple du
pacifique et donc je sais que le sénat a
commencé à travailler sur ce sujet me
suis entretenu d'ailleurs avec le le
président buffet avant lui le président
philippe bas se sont vraiment une
question essentielle quel modèle
veux-t-on avoir pour nos de rome la
réunion il a répondu il ya maintenant de
nombreuses années je vois que en
guadeloupe il n'y a pas de consensus le
ministre lui rallumer bien dire des
choses venir très forte en disant que la
loi de la république doit s'appliquer
parce que c'est un département et région
d'outre-mer ça c'est une vraie question
qui pour lequel également il faudra
regarder le statut particulier des îles
du nord dont celle que vous représentez
madame la sénatrice belge jacques
monsieur le ministre les collectivités
connaissent leur territoire et prendre
en compte leur regard permet d'ajuster
les décisions dans l'intérêt des
populations locales et cela vaut qu'elle
soit départements collectivités
d'outre-mer à l'instar de saint
barthélémy qui durait s'demande en
connaissance de la réalité locale une
nouvelle organisation de la prévoyance
sociale il y a urgence à prendre des
décisions pour ramener la sérénité mais
j'insiste sur la nécessaire vision à
long terme à laquelle le sénat est très
attaché
à la parole et à notre collègue a nié le
héros pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et avaient bu du lait
[Applaudissements]
chargée de l'égalité à la veille du 25
novembre journée internationale pour
l'élimination de la violence à l'égard
des femmes à la veille de la fin du
quinquennat l'heure est au bilan plus de
cent de femmes tuées à ce jour plus
qu'en 2021 selon la dernière étude de la
fondation des femmes quatre victimes de
violence sur dix qui formalise une
demande n'ont aucune solution
d'hébergement
seuls 12% des victimes de violence
bénéficie d'une classe avec une prise en
charge adaptée
solidarité femmes indiquent les chiffres
sont encore plus alarmants que ce que
nous avions en tête il faudrait
multiplier par cinq les hébergement
sécurisé avec un accompagnement social
juridique psychologique pour les femmes
et leurs enfants
plus de 22 mille femmes auraient besoin
d'un l'image d'un hébergement pour
sortir des violences puis d'un logement
social or fin 2021
7820 places d'hébergement étaient
disponibles soit 1500 de plus qu'en 2018
c'est mieux c'est très insuffisant pour
la grande cause déclaré pour ce
quinquennat le haut conseil est
l'égalité pointe aussi du doigt un
manque alarmant de places d'hébergement
spécialisés non mixtes et sécuriser le
rapport fin mai ruralité de la
délégation aux droits des femmes du
sénat dont ma collègue marie pierre
monnier est l une des rapporteurs
indique que 50 % des féminicides ont
lieu en ruralité alors que seulement 35
% des familles bib l alerte sur la
nécessité de places d'hébergement
d'urgence dans les zones rurales
l'éviction du conjoint violent associé à
l' ordonnance de protection au téléphone
graves dangers sont des avancées mais
ces mesures ne suffisent pas madame la
ministre
partagez-vous ce bilan et ses
évaluations et quelles réponses pour
l'hébergement et le logement social à la
hauteur des besoins de ces femmes et de
ces enfants en danger
[Applaudissements]
en charge de l'égalité hommes femmes à
moreno de la parole je vous remercie
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
madame la sénatrice annie le houérou
nous savons évidemment combien
l'hébergement est un élément essentiel
dans le processus de sortie des
violences conjugales et c'est la raison
pour laquelle avec emmanuelle wargon
nous avons été extrêmement mobilisés sur
cette question depuis le début de ce
quinquennat et nous nous sommes
d'ailleurs à ce titre réuni lundi avec
des bailleurs sociaux avec des
administrations et des associations en
charge de l'hébergement et du relogement
des femmes victimes de violence et nous
nous étions d'ailleurs déjà réunis au
mois de mai dernier pour travailler
ensemble sur ce sujet est créé un comité
de suivi des places d'hébergement alors
pour en revenir sur les questions des
places d'hébergement vous avez raison
nous partons de très très très très loin
et donc même si nous avons augmenté le
nombre de places d'hébergement depuis
2010 est de 60% ça n'est malheureusement
pas suffisant parce que les efforts
précédemment n'ont pas été à la hauteur
des attentes nous avons créé depuis 2000
vingt deux mille places d'hébergement
supplémentaires qui sont non mixtes et
qui sont dédiées aux femmes victimes de
violence ainsi qu'à leurs enfants fin
2021 nous aurons ainsi
7800 places dédiées aux femmes victimes
de violences ainsi qu'à leurs enfants et
nous avons nous avons également entre
octobre 2019 et septembre 2021 attribué
plus de vingt mille logements sociaux
aux femmes victimes de violence soit une
augmentation de 30% par rapport à 2010
est alors je suis d'accord avec vous il
faut rester humble parce qu'il y a
encore beaucoup de choses à faire mais
on ne peut pas refuser les efforts et
les progrès qui ont été faits depuis
alors c'est la raison pour laquelle avec
emmanuelle wargon nous continuons de
travailler sur ce sujet pour aller
encore plus loin et nous avons mis en
place un véritable plan pour promouvoir
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
dans l'hébergement et le logement ce
plan s'appuie sur deux axes 1 nous
allons former dès le premier trimestre
2009 anne de tous les centres
d'hébergement qui accueille des femmes
au repérage et à l'accompagnement des
victimes et puis nous allons en deuxième
point faciliter l'accès au logement
social pour les femmes victimes de
violences et sur le logement social on
les dit tout à l'heure nous allons
continuer de progresser et nous ferons
en sorte que toutes les femmes qui ont
besoin de se fuir les foyers où elles
subissent ces violences puissent avoir
un lieu où elles se sentent protégés je
vous remercie pour votre héros quelques
secondes madame la ministre a tous
ensemble avec la modestie qui s'impose
que malgré votre engagement cette grande
cause du quinquennat n'a pas été à la
hauteur des besoins que nous devons
mobiliser plus largement pour éradiquer
ce fléau qui tue tous les deux jours
merci la parole et on veut réussir pour
le groupe les
parents
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères ce ministre la france perd
pied en afrique
en qualité de président du groupe
d'amitié france afrique de l'ouest je
dois vraiment le constater avec beaucoup
de regrets
l'influencé économique politiques
diplomatiques ou même culturelle de
notre pays ne cesse de se dégrader au
bénéfice d'autres pays qui jusqu'à une
période récente ne se préoccupait
absolument pas de ce continent jusqu'à
présent cette situation nous préoccupe
est désormais elle nous inquiète elle
nous inquiète car progressivement ce
déclin de la france en afrique semble
changer de nature pour se muer
véritablement en un rouget en
particulier dans la zone d'intervention
de barkan les rassemblements hostiles à
notre pays se sont en effet multipliés
ces derniers mois au mali au niger au
tchad ou dernièrement au burkina faso
dans lequel le 20 novembre dernier il a
quatre jours un convoi des forces
françaises française a été bloqué par
des manifestants
reprochant à la france je cite de ne
rien faire pour stopper les attaques
djihadistes allant même jusqu'à dire je
cite toujours la france et complices des
terroristes
malgré le sacrifice de nos soldats
malgré les succès opérationnels décisif
renfort ont remporté par nos armées sur
les groupes armés djihadistes un
sentiment anti-français d'une virulence
inédite se développe attisées par tous
ceux qui espèrent bénéficier d'une
manière ou d'une autre du déclassement
de notre pays dans cette région dans ces
conditions je crains avant même d'avoir
gagné la guerre que nous ne soyons
confrontés au risque de perdre la paix
une telle issue ne ferait que des
perdants
africains comme européens face à un
terrorisme islamique qui ne désarme pas
mais cette dégradation de l'image de la
france je dis bien de l'image de la
france ne s'observe pas qu'au sahel elle
a également cours dans le reste de
l'afrique de l'ouest et même au maghreb
il est donc urgent d'agir pour inverser
la tendance monsieur le ministre comment
le gouvernement compte il s'attachait à
cette tâche certes difficile mais
indispensable pour notre pays et
l'afrique
pour vous répondre par olic à la
déléguée en charge la mémoire d'un
ancien combattant madame darrieussecq
vous avez la parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
opposés une question importante
concernant l'afrique
la présence de notre pays en afrique et
l'action qu'elles y mènent
d'abord je voulais vous parler du convoi
terrestre donc que vous avez évoqué ce
convoi terrestre et qui ravitaille
barkan est effectivement bloqué au
burkina faso depuis le 18 novembre je
voudrais vous rassurer ce convoi est
aujourd'hui stationnés en sécurité près
de ouagadougou
et au sein d'une caserne de gendarmerie
burkinabé je voudrais également vous
dire que les dialogues avec les
autorités burkinabé les forces de
l'ordre burkinabé est permanent et que
ce convoi n'a rien d'exceptionnel
parce que c'est un convoi c'est le 32e
convoi qui est envoyé pour rejoindre la
bande sahélo saharienne
et pour bien sûr transporter les
ressources pour marquer alors
aujourd'hui vous le savez le burkina
faso est dans une situation sécuritaire
très fragile l'attak d'inata du 14
novembre à créer un véritable émoi dans
la population
cinquante trois gendarmes qui ont été
tuées
et bien sûr
la population s'indigne et la population
ça suscite une véritable frustration
auprès de la population
car elle est la première victime des
attaques terroristes
alors bien sûr nous mettons tout en
oeuvre pour lutter contre la
désinformation la désinformation existe
dans ces pays et les quelques fois
activés par des forces étrangères
qui se veulent influente danser dans ces
états
nous faisons tout pour lutter contre la
désinformation
mais je crois que notre rôle majeur sera
bien entendu de faire en sorte avec ces
états qu'ils aient une stabilité
politique et qu'il puisse regagner la
confiance de leurs populations également
en créant du développement il
développement ciblé mais efficace et je
crois que ce n'est qu'à ce moment là que
nous pourrons apaiser ces tensions vis à
vis de populations qui sont déroutés par
ces attaques terroristes permanente
voilà ce que je peux vous dire
aujourd'hui monsieur le sénateur
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
nathalie goulet pour le groupe de
l'union
le président mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues je
voudrais vous exprimer mon inquiétude
je travaille depuis longtemps sur les
questions de financement du terrorisme
l'autriche a récemment interdit les
frères musulmans de son territoire et
fin octobre un rapport alarmiste a été
publiée sur leur financement dans le
même temps l'europe absolument sans état
d'âme à financer des organisations
proches des frères musulmans adeptes du
ramasse qui viennent encore de faire
couler le sang à jérusalem le cas
islamic relief est particulièrement
emblématique accusés de liens avec les
réseaux terroristes et les frères
musulmans la commission européenne et
coûtait bien monsieur le ministre la
commission européenne a certifié sa
filiale allemande islamic relief germany
comme un partenaire humanitaire 2021 et
2027 lui accordant
712 milles euros de subventions alors
que dans le même temps l'allemagne a
engagé une procédure pour faire
interdire les frères musulmans de son
territoire en france le même groupe
islamique relish a évidemment un
satellite le secours islamique qui
renvoie environ 800 mille euros par an à
la maison mère en grande bretagne je
vous rappelle quand même que ces braves
gens nous explique que les juifs sont
les petits enfants des singes et des
porcs salue le groupe terroriste ramasse
comme le mouvement le plus pur de
l'histoire moderne encense ses
dirigeants les décrivent comme les
grands hommes qui ont répondu à l'appel
du divin sacré de la fraternité
musulmane des gens tout à fait
recommandable
monsieur le ministre quand allez-vous
mettre un terme à ces financements et
quand allez vous interdire islamic
relief du territoire français
la parole est au ministre délégué chargé
du commerce extérieur de l'attractivité
bien merci monsieur le président madame
dessinatrice messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices goulet d'abord je voudrais
redire avec shalit et que la france
condamne avec la plus grande fermeté
l'attaqué terroriste qui était père
prêté le 21 novembre dernier dans la
vieille ville de jérusalem
nous présentons évidemment nos
condoléances à la victime et ont
souhaité en des preuves de
rétablissement aux blessés
au-delà de cet attentat grave je
voudrais évidemment réaffirmé que la tag
le dr de dimanche dernier a été vous
l'avez rappelé revendiquée par le hamas
le hamas qui est depuis 20 ans est
inscrit sur la liste des organisations
terroristes la décision vous avez évoqué
sur les britanniques celle au royaume
uni la semaine dernière d'une
inscription de l'ensemble du mouvement
sur la livre britannique des
organisations terroristes ne rien
d'autre qu'un rattrapage par rapport au
cadre juridique européen
en fait depuis leur exil seule la
branche armée du hamas était considérée
comme terroriste dans le droit
britannique et la décision annoncée et
temps cette mesure à l'ensemble du
mouvement ce qui ne fait que rejoindre
en fait une réalité applicable depuis
longtemps dans l'ensemble des états
membres de l'union européenne sur la
question plus large que vous évoquez des
mouvements radicaux antisémite appelant
la haine ou à la violence je veux
rappeler la fermeté absolue du
gouvernement en la matière qui a pris la
décision de dissoudre plusieurs
associations présentes sur le territoire
national à commencer par le collectif
cheikh yacine du nom du fondateur du
hamas et s'inscrit dans la politique
plus large du gouvernement dans la loi
confortant les principes de la
république porté par le gouvernement et
qui renforce les dispositifs de
détection et de sanction contre les
actes qui portent atteinte aux intérêts
de la nation madame la sénatrice à ce
titre vous le savez nous avons renforcé
nos moyens notamment dans le cadre du
contrôle des financements des
associations traque fin aux cas
particuliers qui travaillent activement
depuis plusieurs années sur les
financements étrangers dont ceux en
provenance du moyen-orient et qui
dispose désormais de sources
d'information et de le et juridiques qui
seront plus efficaces dans ces combats
qui sont les nôtres je vous remercie
madame la sénatrice
yeux me laisse franchement rien c'est
pas de chance parce que sourd et
financement du terrorisme les deux
mesures qui renforcent les financements
et notamment le fait de pouvoir utiliser
traque fin pour contrôler les cagnottes
en ligne et les collectes ont sauté lors
de la commission mixte paritaire ça
avait été voté par le sénat le ministre
le compte n'y est pas sur ces
dispositifs la france va présider
l'union européenne très bientôt j'espère
que vous mettrez ce sujet du financement
du terrorisme en tête de vos priorités
parce que franchement c'est une
nécessité absolue faut assécher ses
mouvements terroristes
les messieurs les ministres merci nos
prochaines questions d'actualité auront
lieu le mercredi 1er décembre
je vais suspendre la séance et sera
reprise à 16h30 pour la nouvelle lecture
du projet de loi de finances
rectificative pour 2021 la séance est
suspendue